welcome to this video playing a
kazillion kazillion to probably improved
version of kazillion wherever that is
okay we have one dutch defense i could
play the stone wall i haven't done that
before on video well maybe maybe you
wanna stop twice it's not such a bad
opening really am especially if white is
committed to Knight f3 I don't it's one
of those one of those i'm not sure if
there's even another comparable opening
we're actually black has got a space
advantage in the center with those parts
of course the drawback is them on other
weaknesses on the light squares but it's
not such a big deal the light squared
Bishop is often yeah described as being
the problem of blacks position but it is
in fact quite often the case that
White's bishop is not much better if you
look at this is the bishop p.m. is
mostly looking at a black wall of pawns
okay let's see how to how to develop him
he exchanged the dark squared Bishop
quickly but we can't answer queenside in
the process I'm not sure how to play
that hmm yeah maybe maybe night before
I'm not sure it it's may be helpful to
exchange this a six-night that it's not
that's not doing so much with the spawn
formation on the queenside it's not so
easy for him to do anything on that side
let's say a capture would make that
would make the pawn structure completely
frozen a while wonder if he if he plays
c5 where's my queen going a 93 I can
take hmm it's this may be very dangerous
for my queen Wow nah yeah I guess it
wasn't fatal but again I better retreat
this never know better retreat
okay so what am I going to do next a
classic rootin for this Bishop is of
course d 78 h5 to get it out of the pawn
chain maybe this is what I will do yeah
night to d3 he might put it on f4 or 1c5
I mean I don't I don't think that'd be
six is a great way to develop here which
is sometimes a good alternative and the
stone wall but it does not look right
here in this position is he setting up
the counters don't roll with F for this
is always always a very oh no he's
taking and that that's surprising why
exactly no no no I thought he would he
prepares who
interesting as I didn't expect any of
that interesting if i take no it takes
you there is some there's some slight
pressure on the queenside yeah it's not
the end of the world but still not sure
that I want to do that okay I don't know
yeah I think he should retreat now just
to d3 keep keep the pressure on ya and
now with before coming up
hmm tricky tricky position yeah but I
had an idea going here and then to a six
I thought he should prevent that not
sure maybe he can allow it and it's not
really a problem where why is he heading
to see five I know to see seven I can
maybe just play Bishop have one at the
right at the right moment
yeah that's possible okay I I can take
and play and be six at some that's
possible I have the king near the action
this is important should I place you 5c
four hmm I don't know don't I don't I
don't have enough time to figure it out
okay let's do that it's a very committal
decision yeah this is a good move but
maybe I can take and play voxxi for Nazi
for take here I blundering something I
don't time well it looks like looks a
bit shaky I don't I don't see it
now to take a form and she will give the
check here
yeah it's just a draw check not much I
can do about it
I played a good game so no why wait why
am i giving up that I didn't really pay
attention okay it was was not necessary
at all to do
hmm grah offered yeah I offered the draw
I mean I think this is Laura offered gay
humming challenge yeah he's on his
unknown he's on to a second so he would
lose on time but ok the position is is
just lost full i guess yeah assembly i
had forgot I forgot that he I didn't
really look at it that he'll text the
porn I can I can I like him and I not
can I must I must check here of course
and then and continue from down like
this and then I don't know just just
continue I don't think white can win
this there should be a draw yeah i
played this very well may be here Joe
this is just leading to a draw what can
you do I was trying to play it play I am
playing for women I wanted to avoid this
this one here because the sea search
yeah this Genesis was just 22 draws to
me I thought maybe I can do something
here but ok this is nonsense yeah the
only way this is not going to be a draws
that like to do this but he didn't do
anything anything stupid at all he
played it very well yeah and yeah I
simply forgot to cover the deep one and
this now has lost I guess yeah this is
just lost
ja oh something and there was also
something bad in the opening I don't I
well i'm not an expert on this would be
interesting to know i mean i know that
this is this is normal like it with a 5
yeah this should be quite quite normal
but maybe here there's something maybe
maybe something like that this could be
could be the way to go then Bishop d7
rook c8 and so on yeah I don't know this
opening too well alright thanks for
watching